good to see everyone this is not going
to be a typical stream I'm gonna be
doing analysis of the over the board
game that I played which finished
finished like 90 minutes ago played at
the st. Louis chess club for those who
don't know tournament just began the st.
Louis norm Congress people can read
through this starts today it's nine
rounds it ends I want to say Tuesday
yeah ends on Tuesday most days have two
games a day finish round one I had a
draw against Aaron Jacobsen and is a
very hard-fought draw actually blunder
like pretty early in the game and then
I'm I'm very thankful not to lose so I
think what I'll do is I'll show the game
I'll keep an eye on the chat Spain Aleph
says play the London I did not play the
London this game even though I was white
I played the English don't get mad at me
I was trying to surprise my opponent c4
is yeah it's another move that I'm
capable of playing I wasn't sure
entirely what to expect I thought my
opponent could play e5 or Knight f6 or
ecigs
he playing that f6 I play tonight c3 c5
so this is a typical English position
and in the past in this position I've
played Knight f3 which is one of the
main moves maybe g3 is the most common
move this position I played somewhat of
a sideline pawn III which let's see
let's take a look at opening database
Pawnee three third most popular move
yeah it's the type of line which is not
the most radical but as black I play the
time on of Sicilian and all these moves
are are included in time on of so
essentially what we got was a time on of
a tempo Aaron played knight c6 I played
a three
then he actually surprised me I was
expecting maybe g6 or g6 you play d5
entering reverse open Sicilian which I
was quite happy with because this is a
position I play as black and just to
demonstrate actually if we go back to
move one if I'm black one of my main
openings is this take stakes here here
here so essentially we got this position
but I got a six included and it's always
weird like sometimes these openings like
one small tempo can make a difference
but as we'll see I don't think it made a
huge difference going back to the game
okay a three included Aaron took on c3
which is very playable and it creates a
situation where maybe a three is not the
most useful useful move I was honestly
hoping for is something like this and
then I could maybe go for early Bishop
b5 but okay he took and then I decided
to take back with the b-pawn I had the
feeling that maybe Queen takes is is a
better way to justify a three because
then I have before and it should be two
but this is a structure after it B takes
c3 it's a structure I've played many
times as black and it's essentially this
line after it takes takes and with or
without the pawn on on a6 it's not the
most challenging line for black to deal
with because d5 is is very natural so
it's something I've had experience in so
you take c3 and I was playing relatively
quickly Bishop d6 d4 and he was taking a
lot of time I think like care all these
moves were pretty natural I think by the
time we got to this position I've used
maybe like 2 or 3 minutes off the clock
and my opponent had already used like
half-hour but I was content with the
structure mix we G saying I played
Sicilian last night my opponent blender
2-piece on move eighths
well I blundered on move 13 in this game
and it was like really careless blunder
to as as we'll see but okay I play
rookie one and one thing about this
position is that white isn't necessarily
scared of e4 no maybe it looks scary
so after here f5 the idea of playing c4
is quite quite annoying for black
because I'm c5 ideas maybe even d5 ideas
also Knight c4 here also possible so I
think I think my opponent made a good
choice not going for a for too early I
should also note that okay when I play
rook e1 and allow e4 there is a line I
have to calculate it's like probably the
most forcing line efore here and then
Bishop takes h2 and I just have to make
sure this isn't losing for me
so here here here I actually don't think
there's too many moves to survive here
however there is one move which I'm
pretty sure survives and is just winning
for whites so I'll leave it up to the
Czechs whites and move what's the best
move Black has Czech meaning threats
what to do your instinct says a Knight
takes e4 Knight takes e4 rook h6
now there's some funny lines I don't
think Knight takes e4 works actually
maybe it somehow it does but rook aged
six maybe you want to play Knight g3 the
problem is blacks meaning after Queen hu
Queen each one takes in mate and why
can't play f3 allowing this move so f3
also takes Queen jc1 immediately so as
far as I can see there's a couple people
that got it
King h9x lamb and M Walker
yeah just g3 very simple move put the
question to the Queen if the Queen moves
h3 I have Bishop f1 and then Bishop g2
and I'm just up a piece and this is weak
and life is good so yeah it's something
to be aware of and it's something that I
didn't really have to calculate it's
just based on experience I know this
type of calculation doesn't work so my
opponent played b6 b6 looks like a
really random move to someone who has
maybe a bit less experience in these
types of structures but it's actually
very very logical Black has ideas of
Knight a5 and c5 and very often in these
types of positions black wants to go for
some positional play in the center
rather than the King side attack so b6
of what's the ball in my course and in
this position I just I played very
carelessly like I basically considered
okay I considered two moves but I played
way too quickly well I should've jhanas
played Bishop b2 and prepare c4 and be
happy what I did
d5 was not a huge consideration d5 is a
little bit overextending and could allow
the Knights to hop in later to c5 and
also allows out five with just nice
pawns for black
yeah so the move I played here was pawn
c4 which is very very thematic for this
sort of position I mean next move I want
to play this and I assume that after
takes takes I'd be happy here maybe even
ideas of Bishop to e3
I played c4 when I wasn't really sensing
any danger and I really should have been
sensing the danger here because Black
has everything kind of supporting the
center and I'm a little bit
underdeveloped and it turns out that
black has tactics here which I was
completely oblivious to only until after
I played the move like right after I
played c4 that I started realizing oh
like d4 h 2 and a 1 they're all targets
so in this position black to move and
find some nice tactic we didn't go into
this in the game I think it's if I allow
this and it's really bad ok who's this
person electron basket
yeah Knight takes d4 also mix squeegee
finding the right move Knight takes d4
Knight takes d4 and Queen e5 would be
very hurtful for me hitting the pollen
threatening meet also skewering and I'm
temporarily up a piece but I'm losing
material hello to the ice so I wanted to
go into this line and okay
of course he he did take on on d4 and
then I started thinking for I took a
very long thing here I had an hour and
24 minutes at this point and I thought
until I had maybe 50 minutes but he took
a long thing before taking because he
was making sure the lines were working
out so after he took he had maybe like
24 minutes okay so I thought for about
35 minutes
and I decided that if I do allow this
it's bad I was calculating Knight f3
Queen takes a one and then Bishop to b2
which almost works like the queen is
almost trapped but he has this move work
take situ and things simplify I can't
take the Queen because then I lose my
own queen I can't take this way because
I I'm pinned so I can take this way but
then Queen a2 and blocks just up upon I
was trying to dig deeper and find
counterplay but I mean this is hanging
this is a threat White's just busted
here so I took a long time in this
position because I can't go for the line
that I initially wanted to play which is
this and then I wanted to play Bishop to
d3 but Bishop d3 runs into Bishop g4 and
I'm also hurting here as Bishop takes a
three as a threat I can't take because
this pawn is pinned I can't take the
other way because then Queen takes a one
takes takes Bishop f1 and then take some
92 is coming and I'm just lost so it's a
very painful position because like the
two moves I want to play Bishop d3 or
pawn takes pawn neither of them work so
I thought like at this point maybe 10 to
20 minutes into my think I thought I was
just gonna lose like I thought I had to
like go for one of these lines and just
be down material but then I found a
somewhat creative approach which
involved okay it doesn't involve giving
some material every line I'm losing
material but it created complications
and the move I played was Bishop to b2
and at first it looks terrible because
after pawn takes pawn this is a threat
this III pawn is well supported but
somehow after Bishop to d3 it became a
little bit tricky because my bishops
were actually quite happy and my rook
was aligned with the Queen
and I'm sure there is some way for for
buck to be better here but during the
game it wasn't that obvious a lesson for
you here always connect your rooks yeah
I think this is a important lesson like
even at the higher levels like before
the before you allow the center to open
up your rook should be connected so c4
it was just too early to premature
there should be two to connect the rooks
first it is much better
sorry I don't fall victim to use tactics
on anyone okay so I play Bishop b2 I
should also note that I'm not using
stockfish for this analysis I know the
stockfish analysis is on me chess well
they actually did I had to download the
lead chess game remove the annotations
and then put it into a new study just to
make sure that there's no there's no
analysis here but if you don't want to
look at this with analysis you're you're
more than welcome to do so I can share
this study in the chats and if I put
this on youtube
I'll share this study in the youtube
video description so there should be two
takes Bishop d3 and the good thing for
me was I was I was doing decently on
time and okay he was taking a long time
hearing cuz it's not that easy because I
my bishops are scary his Queen's a
little bit a little bit in danger so you
decided to take and now I have to take
with King sadly if I take with Queen I
run into Bishop c5 and that would be a
bad so I take with King
so I'm down upon my kings on f2 but
somehow I still had compensation
he plays Bishop c5 I play King f1 and
then this is where I kind of start
dictating play
he plays Queen played Queen d6 and the
thing here I win back one pawn so even
though I'm I'm down two pawns I'll win
age seven he had to play here or here I
believe so Queen d6 was natural I take
here and then I had to be accurate like
I wanted to play rook a d1 rook a d1
runs in Tobruk take c1 and then it's not
great for me whatever I take back with
so I played Brooke II d1 avoiding the
trade hitting the Queen and the Queen
was a little bit tied down to the bishop
now I was actually starting to feel
decently here like I felt so badly a few
moves ago after pawn takes d4 but then
like time was on my side I had
initiative he played Queen e6
after the game he was thinking Queen h6
was better and then we could go into the
sign takes takes ticks ticks ticks and
it's equal material and we were
analyzing a little bit like 95 I think
both sides still have chances I have an
active rook but my pawns are a little
bit weak yeah I was up on time pretty
much the whole game until the very end
I'll have to get to the end because
there was many there are many different
stages to this game so we played Queen
e6 I played rook to d5 which I was very
happy about like the rook is hard to
attack and I'm threatening work h5 also
ideas of rook e1 or d1 so I felt like I
had sufficient compensation for the pawn
and then after the game he was saying
still Queen h6 and we would actually go
into the same line but he played out
five
now five I think was a mistake because I
win the pawn back and I keep control
it's attempting to trap the bishop but
the problem for black is after rook e1
I'll eventually take on e8 and either
his bishop his rook or his queen will
have to recapture which means I'll have
three attackers against two defenders on
f5 so that's essentially what happened
Queen f7 was played I took on e 8 takes
and now here I actually took a long
think I mean okay the most natural move
of course is just taking a five winning
back upon but I really wanted to play
Queen d2 with so many beautiful ideas
like one idea is that if Bishop e6 I
have Queen h6 and I think I'm I'm just
crushing here because I'm threatening
meat I'm also threatening this so like
if Queen upset and I just do this and
beat so the pin is is just so deadly and
then if I think there's 94 here but then
something like I could even take with
Bishop maybe takes with Bishop in Queen
h4 and it's so difficult for black
actually maybe Queen each three point h3
and this is coming so I wanted to show
something really cool here after Queen's
eggs Yates
I wanted to play Queen d2 with this idea
okay so I showed the idea of Queen h6
attacking the bishop I was calculating
this really fascinating line Jonathan
Sampson thanks for subbing with twitch
prime I did not officially I'm not the
chess bra I'm just living in the chess
bra apartment or the chess rock cave I
guess is what we call it
so yeah and I'm using their they're
amazing immaculate setup right now but
I'm in st. Louis I'm playing the the st.
Louis more in Congress so I was
calculating Bishop III here I really
wanted to go into this but I had no idea
what was going on and I thought it might
just be losing for me to a [ __ ] of III
rook takes d7 Bishop takes d2 rook takes
g7 I'm down the Queen for a minor piece
down the queen for a bishop
well it looks so fun hey it's a thousand
bits from the abandoned castle
thanks for the bits so we were actually
having some fun like analyzing this
after the game there there are a few
other players who who this position
caught the attention of like JJ was was
analyzing and chess we was there and it
was it's just so confusing for me like I
don't like these types of positions
where like it could it could just be
losing it might be winning but it's
probably losing somehow I forget what we
were analyzing Bishop I mean bishops he
ones a move also 95 maybe playable like
there's weird ideas 95 we're now the
rooks attacked and if takes takes takes
takes and I'm down the exchange in my
Bishop stuck but then we were looking at
this slide rook takes you seven and I'm
still threatening the Knights but then
there's Bishop f4 and I think we were
looking at night h4 g3 it's just so
confusing but then rook f7
yeah chess we'd chess we've seen such a
strange position probably later I'll
analyze this with stockfish but I'll
leave it a mystery for now I would guess
black is somehow winning but I don't
know what about rook f7 immediately
wait rook f7 in this position rook f7 in
this position I just take Rick f7 this
position I can still take the problem is
when I take its check to the king in
naive org f7 oh wait it keeps going so
this is a mainline rook takes e7 bishop
yeah Bishop f4 knight eh for rogue f7o
bishop yeah we were analyzing this
position it's so ridiculous
like there's so many pins I'm still down
the Queen what is this anyway
food for thoughts let's go back in terms
of like the practical nature I thought I
mean I thought I could just take and
this is just it's easier to understand I
thought I'm slightly better here we
traded and then he plays King g8 which
kind of surprised me I was expecting
Queen e3 I think this leads to a draw
because this is a really annoying threat
and then we were looking afterwards like
I could play Knight h4 but then there's
some annoying perpetual if I play King
g1 then there's this move here and then
takes and wins the queen or wins a
knight
also after Queen III we could we could
draw by by me giving perpetual so he
played King and g8 just sorta surprise
me told me after the game he didn't want
an immediate draw he just wanted to keep
it going maybe create some chances but
my time situation was nice
I played Queen d5 which I thought was
natural move many surprised me he played
Queen a7 which at first I thought like
the the first three seconds of looking
at this move I thought oh free piece but
then I realized if I take the Knights
Queen takes c4 and I'm losing my queen
this is the only legal move and then
okay Bishop f2 and he wins the Queen so
I didn't take the poison I decided that
there's no great square for my queen so
we traded and I thought why it is like
slightly slightly better here because my
King comes to a nice square and I can
get to e4 essentially before he gets
before he prevents me like my king is
guaranteed to come to e4 because like I
played g4 at some point and then I just
control all of these squares and then I
have the potential of the outside pass
pawn like g4 h4 and his pawns are that
slower to move and then on top of that I
had a nice time advantage I was still up
mmm still at maybe 20 20 25 minutes on
the clock
he had less than 10 minutes at this
point if I go forward kingi to g6 King D
3 and there was a point where I felt
like I was very close to a win so I
played all the kind of natural looking
ones played a four here was actually
debating in the game because I know he
wants to play d5 stir baiting if I
should play like Knight g5 first
thinking Knight g5 if he plays King e7 I
play this or maybe I play this just
thinking about some funny line like kini
4 here and then I I forked these pieces
but of course he has King g7 so it was
tricky to evaluate I figured a 4 is
flexible like I want to play a four
anyway get the pollen off the dark
square B 4 is not a concern at all I
just play CUNY 4 here that's lights
doing nothing
looks like king of the hill yeah this
was king of the hill I would win I was
not thinking that during the game so he
was a long time I was feeling decent
yeah at this point he was probably less
than 5 minutes
94 to trail off pieces and you're
winning you know the other yeah I I
didn't want to play 94 the problem is I
lose a pawn because he takes once he
doesn't have to take again he can take
on a three so if I could somehow force a
trade of all them on your pieces then
yeah maybe there would be winning
chances without side passer but but yeah
I think the strategy here is to like
slow down the Queen side and then make
headway on the Kings side so he played a
97 I think this is a bad move I think we
were saying after the game like the
bishop should be on e7 and the knight
should somehow get to c5
so I was thinking Bishop e7 and then
maneuver the knight and offers black a
better kind of setup
but he played 97 this made me happy play
Knight g5 and then h4 so yeah his King
was actually forced away he can't move
it's funny he can't move to any of these
squares the knight Bishop and pawns are
nicely coordinating and if he plays King
g6 I'm very happy to play Knight e4 I'll
say King King can go anywhere I'm gonna
take the bishop next he can't take back
with the King because Bishop a3 and I'm
pretty sure this is like completely
winning for whites it's outside passer
bishop first Knights this upon fixed on
the dark square so King D 7 best move H
for c6 I thought it was very very close
to winning here because it turns into a
race I play h5 take stakes then he
played the move which I initially forgot
about but I still thought I had chances
by 9 to 5
stopping the pawn and that's the
question how I actually make progress
because there's there are a few
different options for me even while I
played in the game didn't seem to work I
really wanted to play Knight f7 this is
so close to winning so if I can control
h6 I can just push and like for example
I was calculating this this this this
and I'm just queening he can't access g7
because my bishop
the problem with 9f 7 is he has Bishop
f8 controlling each six and then it's
very hard to make progress his king is
ready to attack the Knights he's ready
to trade so what was the time control
for this game it was 90 minutes with a
30-second increments so after every move
we get in additional 30 seconds which
means we have to take notation for the
whole game so yeah at this point like
after Knight f5 he was already less than
2 minutes but my time was ticking down
too so I was trying to calculate like
this I also really wanted to play this
move Bishop g7 it's a really funny move
because after it takes here it looks
like I'm just I'm good Queen however
black has black has at least one way to
stop the pawn Knight H 5 H 7 and then
Knight f4 and I comes back to g6 just in
time so um I do see questions I'm gonna
hold off until the end to answer
questions well I will take questions
about this game
Oh someone saying Bishop c1 bishop c1
may be in this position to prepare h6 I
think it's too slow like King here nine
nights kicked I move here then King goes
back I'm out Lee chess I'll share that
weakest link again if people want to
analyze if you want to analyze on your
own you can go to this link so well I
ended up fighting I kind of played on
intuition but I was trying to calculate
I played King g4 maybe on the surface
this looks like a blunder because I get
Forks and I lose a pawn but the point is
after Knight g3 King f3 takes King G for
the Knights trapped controlling all
these squares
and then it's a matter of somehow
winning the resulting endgame but I
think he played very precisely
he played Bishop III gotta win the
Knights and he just completely
simplifies takes takes and it's a really
interesting position like if my king is
on f4 it like if I get one tempo it
should be winning but he played b5 yeah
so it was a really crazy game I mean
there are so many stages in this game
like I thought I was gonna lose after 13
moves and then it got really complicated
like this whole attack on the Kings side
and then the endgame is still very crazy
so yeah after b5 the problem for me is
that if I allow like let's imagine I
just moved back this is a move I would
want to play the problem is he just
takes on c4 and even if I went all his
pawns it's not enough to win the game he
just walks his King to eight and it's a
theoretical draw this Bishop is the
wrong color Bishop so I had to keep I
had to keep the C pawn I can't give away
the C pawn like if I'm gonna win this
game
I have to play c5 so I played c5 it's
only a move and then he plays King e6
and this is a problem is that my King is
kind of boxed outs and his Kings coming
to d5 but my pawn is on the darks where
it could be defended so I played Bishop
a3 after the game he was saying what was
he saying
Bishop d4
I thought Bishop III gave me the best
chances probably everything here is draw
I'll just show it happened
Bishop a3 defending preventing any
before and he plays King d5 and then I
have a couple choices I can try and go
around this way or I could try and come
back this way
I thought King f6 was my best try then
he played the move which I actually did
not see coming and then I was actually
nervous that I was gonna lose the game
he played a five and then all of a
sudden I'm realizing oh like he wants to
play b4 and he's gonna win the pawn and
if takes takes these pawns are really
fast and my King was actually completely
out of play I just forgot about 85 I was
calculating I thought his only idea was
like bring the King to b3 and then I
thought I calculated a win here sure
King c4 King c4 I was gonna play King e6
and then one of the main points after b4
takes takes I play this and this this
this this yeah I mean this is just
winning because I have like this or this
an end so I was actually optimistic when
I played keen e6 but he played a five
and then after take stakes I was at this
point below like below two minutes and I
was trying to think like how do i how do
I just simplify for a draw
I played c6 takes I play king e5 and
then he plays b4 I think this is a good
exercise if I'm not mistaken I might be
mistaken but I'm pretty sure there's
only one drawing move for white in this
position so white to move I'll leave it
up to the chats whites and move and draw
I also offered him a draw I offered him
a draw after playing c6 which he
obviously turned down accusal he's the
one trying to win now okay most people
got it
King d4 I mean this is a movie I'd I
played which I know is a draw Bishop
takes b4 is a draw what takes takes here
here right bishop no this is losing for
white
oh it's Bishop b2 yeah just to show this
line this is a classic win here here
here yada-yada
so Bishop b2 strong really
I thought Bishop b2 is losing because of
this and then this this ah maybe I don't
understand
okay I'm gonna use table base because I
wanna use so much mental energy table
this oh so it does a draw Bishop e5 aha
I just wait oh that's brilliant
wait King b3 King do you three Wow
I just wait because black can even get
the pawns to be three and a three
oh here Bishop b2 should be two here
King to three
what ship c1 oh yeah so you get to this
position and like b2 you're in time to
play this a - it's just Bishop b2 okay
so yeah thankfully okay there was uh
there is a simple way of drawing and
then okay I played King d4 and then the
point is after it takes here I just walk
around like even if a for this is just
dead draw so he played king b5 trying to
win so I did not like he knew four so
this is a broadcaster he played I think
he played a for an offer to draw which I
accepted and then we put our kings in
the middle of the board to actually
declare the result you put your the
kings in the center so that's why it's I
Keaney for bikini for was not played
deletes game ended here
if white wins and the kings are placed
on the light squares if black wins the
kings were placed on the darks race so
hopefully that makes sense but yeah it
was a crazy game um I mean I thought it
was close to winning at some point
or maybe at multiple points but I also a
thought I was close to losing like in
this position I thought I thought it was
just dead it's somehow there is calm
feel like this is a position to analyze
with benjin maybe I had something better
and then later to like maybe this
position like somewhere around here
probably this position is something to
analyze as well so I'm gonna probably
put this on youtube so for the YouTube
audience hope you guys enjoyed this I'm
gonna try and do this for every game but
of course it depends on my energy levels
if I have some long games it might take
a few days to actually post these videos
and then I'll leave links in the video
description to leech s study and the
tournament website so you know what's
happening so yeah I'll see you in the
next video